bonjour umberto giovannini
bonjour depuis l'italie bonjour merci et
comment allez vous je vous souhaite une
bonne année il est encore temps oui on
va l'amener ici on va ça va plutôt bien
même si j'espère j'espère en tout cas
les les experts se montrent plutôt
optimistes alors on va parler de la
situation sanitaire en italie l'italie
qui a déjà imposé un pass sanitaires on
en avait déjà parlé avec vous à la fin
de l'année leleu passe maintenant va
être imposé aux bénéficiaires de ce
conte le but du rsa en france et aux
chômeurs c'est une mesure très dur non
oui disons que
je n'ai pas eu cugnaux changement par
rapport au passé à ce qui est maintenant
pour avoir un pass
c'est resté muré des six mois après
avoir été au bac signer avec les deux
boosters au
après avoir guéri locaux vides les prix
moyen de coups et disons qu'il est le
vrai changement est tellement qu'il ya
une décision pour rendre obligatoire
pour les et de plus de 50 ans et
maintenant par contre c'est les maillots
des équipes des restrictions qui sont
faits pour ceux qui n'ont pas le pass
donc vous avez évoqué
demandeurs d'emploi et c'est qui et sur
l'attitude à linz à qui si elle
contient une chaleur universel pour les
- de plus pour les plus démunis mais il
faut dire aussi que menacer aussi très
étroit les accès par exemple
supermarché on peut faire semaine pour
les courses deviennent ici si tu es un
peu plus là il ya une grosse polémique
aussi parce qu'apparemment c'est
interdit aussi de bureaux de tabac mais
les propriétaires des bureaux de tabac
évidemment on n'est pas là pour faire la
police des 13 millions d italiens qui a
lu les revendre mon bureau de tabac mais
aussi notre problème c'est les prix de
l'accès aux bureaux de poste il sachant
que les retraités il ya un grand bar
grosse partie des retraités qui nous
retirer la retraite au bureau de poste
et s'ils n'ont pas leurs passes
vaccinale ils pourront pas accéder aux
bureaux de poste et du cours obtenir là
marie trek
mais disons que maintenant qu'on est
vraiment rentré dans un questionnement
politique il faut pas oublier qu'un
maximum en italie aussi c'est l'élection
du président de la république certes le
président de la république italienne et
a beaucoup moins d'aidés
des pouvoirs est beaucoup moins élevé
des délires des derniers que les
précédents tracé mais actuellement donc
ça fait une grande discussion là aussi
l'histoire ou draghi prise peut-être
quitter les postes de premier ministre
on y venait d'y venir président de la
république nomme bisons qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement des moins connus aimés
des médecins il ya eu des décisions qui
sont prises que cette passe sanitaire
mais qui sont beaucoup plus de l'art de
politique pour faire plaisir à
certainement pas l'âge de novalis provoc
c'est plutôt qu'est médical ça se
délient point de vue médical on arrive à
un plateau actuellement décisions
importantes d'autant que vous l'avez dit
le il ya l'élection dû président italien
en ce moment et pour l'instant aucun
parti ne s'est mis d'accord sur sur le
successeur de matériaux est tout à fait
lui l'unique accord que mahut sait mais
c'est l'heureuse qui vomit qui a décidé
de faire un look un pas en arrière
en me disant qu'ils ont déjà élu à l'âge
il ya aussi des problèmes de santé qui
sont plus ou moins de masquer mais on
sait qu'il ya eu comme idée du problème
en delà des circuits locaux vides il
avait été opéré du coeur il y a quatre
ans encore effectivement et d'avoir
certaines procédures sont encore en
contre lui il n'a pas pu participer pour
des raisons de santé donc disons que
c'était plus serré des gosses qui lui
appartenait quel est le véritable espoir
des limites président de la république
mais dans l'aujourd'hui effectivement il
ya une coalition qui soutient le
gouvernement et qui est et parier les
populistes de la ligue du nord d' des
partitions du pdc le parti démocrate
donc et aucun n'arrive à trouver
l'accord il faut dire aussi que la
droite qui est très majoritaire donc en
fait d'avoir une présidente des boîtes
parce que les derniers préserve n'était
tout issu de la gauche mais là aussi la
droite et même elle n'arrive à trouver
un consensus sur une seule personne
après c'est serré table pour nous la
population que la classe politique même
des incitations des crises aujourd'hui
ne sommes pas capables de sortir au
notaire est proposée aussi une personne
qui puisse être passé du conteur hors du
pays non j'avais quand j'étais enfant
c'était le moment dramatique et vitaly
et finalement non versées on avait sorti
en europe et qui c'est vrai est reconnu
comme président parce que c'est mon
l'aller le besoin d'une figure en dès la
départ qui est là pour le moment je
trouvais dans un marasme à des
politiques magouilles qui dans le roman
de l'image est très sombre de la
politique italienne moments importants
de crise quelle est la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui en italie est ce
qu'elle s'améliore
disons que la situation sanitaire est
stable donc on craignait beaucoup la cei
quelle vague mais il faut dire que
aujourd'hui on colomiers les principes
des traitements déco vide mais dis donc
plutôt les gros soucis actuellement qui
la crise sanitaire nathalie sait plus
trop vite aux conséquences du coc vide
dans le sas comme en retard sur tous les
dépistages sutout la chirurgie et les
protégés d'alex outre la chirurgie
urologique carcinologique donc
finalement aujourd'hui il ya des retards
diagnostic il a des retards de prise en
charge parce qu'il n'ya pas des places
opératoire parce qu'il est vous les
premiers opératoire ils sont en décalé à
cause du
service qui sont saturés copie au même
mois gl moi maintenant je fais presque
je fais du libéra les surtaxes
esthétique mais même dans ces cas là
aujourd'hui on va décaler d'intervention
parce qu'elle a personnel qu'un contact
parce que la personne positive qu'au
vide mais ça ne concédant monde mais les
itérations les doigts très apporter du
coup en attendant en 32 21 surtout la
chirurgie et la médecine de base alors
qu'elle tout le comme il en arrive
actuellement n'a pas trop saturé l'erea
elle pas trop saturé les services
hospitaliers même situation france merci
beaucoup roberto duran i need d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france mais